c'est l'une des contradictions
douloureuses vécues par Israël que
d'avoir à faire subir à un peuple
déraciné un traitement qu'il a lui-même
si longtemps durer à travers le
[Musique]
monde ici s'arrêtait Israël avant la
guerre des 6 jours cette barrière
marquait la frontière qui le séparait du
territoire de
Gaza sur cette étroite bande de terre
qui s'étire le long de la mer s'affronte
depuis an deux grands brimés de
l'histoire les juifs et les Palestiniens
relica du mandat anglais sur la
Palestine Gaza n'a rien connu d'autre
que l'occupation militaire depuis 23
ans depuis la création de l'État
d'Israël par les Nations Unies le 29
novembre
1947 Gaza est devenu un immense camp de
réfugiés où s'entasse près de 300000
palestiniens qui ont abandonné leur
terre pour fuir les combats
occupé pendant 19 ans par l'armée
égyptienne après la première guerre
israélo-arabe de 1948
elle est passée depuis juin 1967 sous le
contrôle de l'armée
israélienne il n'est pas un israélien
qui n dise aujourd'hui Gaza est le
fardeau le plus lourd que nous ayons
apporté étrange calme de cette ville
arrêtée où la plupart des boutiques ne
lèvent plus leur rideau de fer depuis
longtemps où le cinéma n'affiche plus de
film et où les Pho électrique sont
protégé des sabotage par des blocs de
[Musique]
béton le marché qui fut le cœur
palpitant de la cité s'abrite derrière
un filet
antigrenade et les yeux des enfants
gardent la trace des maisons dynamité
par l'armée
d'occupation
lorsque nous sommes arrivés à Gaza le
colonel israélien gouverneur en second
du territoire nous a dit en souriant si
vous êtes venu ici chercher un événement
sensationnel vous ne l'aurez pas à moins
que vous ne sautiez sur une
grenade à Gaza c'est vrai en apparence
il ne se passe
rien il ne s'est rien passé non plus
dans la vie de ces hommes pendant les 19
années de présence égyptienne à Gaza
rien n'a été fait pour diminuer leur
isolement et leur misère la couleur des
uniformes est désormais la même dans
toutes les armées du monde hier les
soldats de l'armée d'occupation étaient
arabes aujourd'hui ils sont
juifs pourrait être merveilleux endroit
de vacances c'est l'un des h ans de
réfugiés palestiniens du territoire de
Gaza ici à beachcamp vivent 30000
personnes sur un espace qui ne dépasse
pas 200
hectares patrouille contrôle identité
fouille font depuis longtemps partie de
la vie quotidienne de ces hommes et de
ses
femmes
[Musique]
c'est dans ces camps que se recrute la
plupart de ceux qui constituent les
commandos de F faire de lance de la
résistance
palestinienne c'est l'une des
contradictions douloureuses vécu par
Israël que d'avoir à faire subir à un
peuple déraciné un traitement qu'il a
lui-même si longtemps duré à travers le
monde
pendant les TR premiers jours de notre
présence à Gaza 16 F ont trouvé la mort
dans des accrochages avec les forces de
sécurité
israélienne
[Musique]
la 3è génération d'enfants est en train
de naître dans les camps de Gaza où la
vie s'est organisée après 1948 grâce à
l'unra agence des Nations Unies pour
l'assistance et l'emploi des réfugiés
palestiniens la carte de réfugiés si
souvent utilisé constitue pour ces gens
le bien le plus précieux peuple oublié
sans identité sans territoire sans
maison elle leur confère au moins un
droit celui de se
plaindre
chaque mois les familles reçoivent les
rations de nourriture qui assurent les
1500 calories journalières
indispensables à la
survie la plupart St
content il y a combien de temps que
cette jeune femme est
là
oui plus de an plus de an elle est dans
ce est estci elle appartient à une
famille qui a beaucoup
d'enfants
[Musique]
oui ces constructions provisoires ont
été édifiées par l'unra en
1948 pour permettre aux Palestiniens
d'attendre le règlement de leurs problèm
ils attendent toujours
il couche à 6 quelquefis à 8 dans une
pièce de 6 m
Carr est-ce que cette jeune fille peut
nous faire visiter sa
maison
bienven
la fait elle fait la cuisine sur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoiit la
placeile lecre et
R
sa mère est arrivée dans ce camp quand à
quelle
époque il sa pas
exactement la m
dit848 c'estd à la création des
[Musique]
camp lunra débordé assure tant bien que
mal un minimum d'instruction élémentaire
pour les
enfants il subvient au besoin des
orphelins et procure des soins
indispensable ce qui n'a pas empêché les
camps de Gaza d'être l'an dernier un
foyen important de l'épidémie de
coléra
[Musique]
où est-ce que nous sommes ici nous
sommes dans la chambre où le réfugier
attend
d'entrer pour le docteur c'est c'est la
maternité ça c'est la partie l'hôpital
c'est la partie de la clinique de la
camp
réfugié c'est la partie qui est
consacrée à la maternité oui c'est
[Musique]
C des hommes sans travail une
démographie galopante des conditions de
vie de plus en plus oppressante une
propagande continue incitante à la
révolte les conditions étaient remplies
pour créer une situation
révolutionnaire au mois de septembre
dernier pour juguler la montée du
terrorisme dans les les camp l'armée
israélienne décidait d'ouvrir au
buldozer de larges avenu afin de
contrôler plus facilement la population
il voulait également amorcer par ce
moyen une réorganisation et un
assainissement de la vie dans les camps
plusieurs centaines de maisons ont été
détruites et plusieurs milliers de
personnes touchées par cette
mesure l'apparente tranquillité cache
mal cependant le climat de tension qui
règne depuis ce moment accentué par la
rigueur des représailles exercé par
l'armée
[Musique]
israélienne ce matinl une arme venait
d'être découverte
quelques minutes plus tard la maison
était
dynamitée م علنا
ياسلميننا
يا
عل
يهود
ce jour-là pour la première fois malgré
les conseils de prudence nous sommes
entrés seul dans le camp réputé pour
être le plus
[Applaudissements]
Duria علينا واخذنا
ورفعناحارملمناد هذا اج مص اج ترك
الدن
حهه ما بدناش عمليه توسع ال لان هذه
العمليه مش على توسيع الرق انما على ترحيل
اللاجئين من
معسكراتهمقهم الى سنا والفه الغرب ونح ريد
ننقى سنا
والفهغرب
il y a quelques jours dans ce camp de
dbalia une infirmière américaine avec
qui nous partagions quelquefois nos
repas à trouver la mort au cours d'un
engagement entre les féïes et une
patrouille de l'armée
[Applaudissements]
d'occupation le général barlef ancien
chef d'état-major de l'armée israélienne
déclarait il y a peu de temps le jour
nous contrôlons ce qui se passe à Gaza
la nuit ce sont les féines
pour la première fois cependant quelque
chose est entrepris pour changer la vie
DEES Palestiniens à la sore sud de Gaza
auampbour l'armée israélienne tente sa
première expérience de rénovation des
campson demain l'électricité un point
d'eau dans chaque maison apporter pas d
un véritable boulever dans la vie de la
population à ces hommes désœuvrés Israël
tente d'offrir aujourd'hui des
possibilités de travail chaque matin
vers 5h à l'heure où le muzine égrainene
sa première prière près de 12000 d'entre
eux passent le poste
pour travailler en territoire
israéli il rapporteront des salaires qui
ont fait passer le revenu moyen de leur
famille de 3 livres Après de 10
liv
gazamê une reconversion de l'agriculture
locale est tentée sous la conduite de
moniteurs israéliens on ne cultive plus
seulement pour manger mais aussi et
surtout pour
exporter est-ce que vous gagnez plus
d'argent maintenant ou bien est-ce que
vous en
gagnez pas plus
qu'avant à présent la vérité la réité
est que il gagne trois fois plus que ce
qui
cultiv des cul et
traditionn ces cultures de luxe en
provenance de Gaza commencent à
concurrencer sur les marchés européens
les produits venant
[Musique]
d'Israël
le soir vers 5h les ouvriers de Gaza
retour d'Israël repassent au contrôle et
à la fouille qui peut dire ce qui
s'agite dans le cœur de ces arabes sans
patrie qui peut dire ce qui se passe
dans l'âme de ces soldats israéliens qui
se sont batttu en chantant leur espoir
de retrouver un jour le pays de leurs
ancêtres un JEE soldat juifour g après
la guerre des 6 jours à qui ont demandé
ce qu'il pensait de son rôle d'occupant
répondit c'est une tragédie tout le
problème et de savoir comment se
forgeront les liens humains entre nos
deux peuples et un autre d'ajouter être
une armée d'occupation c'est
moche les responsables israéliens
répondent aujourd'hui comment faire
[Musique]
autrement